this hour we're going to take calls from
those of you that are a millionaire we
want to learn how you've done it the
truth
not what the news media says not what
political parties or people with
ideological agendas against wealth say
because you've heard all the lies let's
help you define what a million areas a
millionaire is not someone that makes a
million dollars a year a millionaire is
someone with a net worth of 1 million
dollars or greater your net worth is
calculated by what you own minus what
you owe your assets minus your
liabilities equals your net worth and so
your house your cars your bank accounts
your investments your 401k - any debt
that you have equals your net worth well
all these people all these rich people
they inherited their money well the
statistics say that's not true 88% of
America's millionaires that's about 9
out of 10 or first generation rich well
all these millionaires are crooks well
we'll ask a few of them and see if they
are then way you get rich rip rip people
off really you really believe that I
mean how many times you go back to a
restaurant or a car dealer or a car
repair place or a dry cleaners that rips
you off how do they get rich again
nobody goes there but once unless you're
stupid
all of them are famous they're athletes
they're entertainers you have to be in
the NFL or the NBA or be a rock star to
be a millionaire no less than 1% of
millionaires are household names people
that you know they're all brilliant they
you have to have a high GPA if they have
a 4.2 you have to have some kind of
intellect that I don't have no average
GPA of a millionaire is right around 3.0
and we'll prove it to you we're going to
ask them and we may talk to somebody
that inherited their money we may talk
to somebody that rip people off we may
talk to somebody that did
but we may not - let's see let's find
out what millionaires are really like
Jack's gonna start us off he's a real
millionaire not a fake one
not a Fiat not a theology and not an
ideology a real guy and he's in
Huntsville Alabama hey Jack how are you
hello there I'm well thank you go to
talk to you what's your net worth sir
2.4 million 2.4 million way to go hero
good job man
what's that invested in how'd you get
that well confess it and mutual fund the
real estate we got it just by saving
living below our mean they even like
crazy my wife had a good career
we both had good jobs but Lisa had a
good career and yeah she'd get different
stock options it were a big start but
yeah what was her career she was a
distribution director okay what do you
do for a living I'm an electronics
technician okay and how old are you guys
I'm 43 and she's 46 wow you're young
millionaires good so how much of the 2.4
million did you guys inherit and 0 okay
and what's your range of income been
since like you were 23 to 43 the last 20
years or so household household income
sure we've been a stay-at-home mom for
the last 10 years prior to that her
income was about 60,000 a year and my
income in the last 20 years is range
from mid 60s for the low 90s oh you guys
have made 100 150 thousand dollars a
year yeah okay range all right cool and
what is a Lisa's degree in she doesn't
have one what about you I've got a
two-year technical degree in electronics
okay what was your GPA um I don't
remember it's been all good while back
but I think it was around 3.0 I wasn't
the smart sharp of kid in class but I
paid attention gotcha cool
and how much of this 2.4 million is
there because you borrowed money to get
rich
Oh zero okay yeah and have you been
using an investment professional to
guide you or have you done this on your
own I have a guy yes at our credit union
I have a guy that helped us okay
gives you advice and then you guys
listen talk about it and pray about it
decide what you're going to do I guess
yeah you know it's more of a he's a
purveyor without a bunch of fees to help
us put it in the right spot but a lot of
financial advisors a little shy about
getting their price if it goes wrong
they don't like that feel like the
accountability so you're kind of on your
own without experience yeah yeah they're
they're scared to death of all the
regulations that's for sure so what part
has giving played in your financial plan
for these last twenty five years it's
been it's been an important part in fact
that's a priority we make some
commitments little part commitment so
that it takes the decision making at the
front of some of it yeah put things in
place if it just happens every month um
Senate that's been a real big part okay
what's the most expensive pair of blue
jeans you ever bought well I normally
pay about twenty bucks at Costco for a
pair of jeans I have much of a much of a
outfit so one time I did spend 90 bucks
thinking I was going to impress my wife
had had quite the opposite effect I
suspect okay yeah I impressed her up
stupid I was percent and mango I love it
Oh before you were a millionaire how
many new cars did you buy oh boy before
as a millionaire we bought a couple
probably two or three okay cool
what advice do you have to the 23 year
old version of you that's listening out
there buy brand new cars do a budget do
something save invest no matter how
small it is or whatever you can squeak
out do it every month and then just be
patient and that's how you guys did this
okay we did it Wow well congratulations
you're absolutely impressive very cool
it's an honor to talk to you sir we
appreciate you calling in Jack from
Huntsville
worth 2.4 million dollars average
household income of 150,000 last 2025
years has invested every single month
and this is what has caused it it's
really not rocket science you guys it's
really not that hard but it requires
this thing that most people don't have
steady and it requires you to live on
less than you make it's inspiring to
hear these stories from people now
listen if you want to know how to do it
go to Chris Hogan's website Chris Hogan
360 dot-com and take the riq the retire
inspired quotient it's an assessment
that will find out how much money you
need to retire it'll show you exactly
step by step how to get there in terms
of how much you need to be saving it's
completely free to do this and you can
pick up a copy of his book retire
inspired that they retire inspired
quotient the r:i q what is your
retirement IQ Chris Hogan 360 dot-com
back with more real millionaires as we
destroy the mythology around the subject
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
Oh